DEAR FRIENDS WITH MARK SANFORD
AND IS VERY ANGRY ABOUT THE WAY
MARK SANFORD WAS TREATED.
SO IT IS GET BACK TIME.
HE'S A 4-YEAR-OLD.
IF HE'S A GREAT LIBERTARIAN WAYS
THAT HE CONCERNED ABOUT THE
SPYING BY THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION?
HE IS A LOSER.
HE DOESN'T CARE ABOUT THE FISA
COURT COMING HE CARES ABOUT
REPEATING THE PRESIDENT AND THAT
IS RIDICULOUS.
>> Laura: THANK YOU SO MUCH,
HAMAS, MICHIGAN STATE JIM LOEHR
REPRESENTED AND JOINS ME, AND IN
CONGRESS FOR NEARLY A DECADE SO
WHY DO YOU THINK THAT YOU CAN
DEFEAT HIM OVER THIS ONE
COMMENT?
THIS ONE COMMENT, THIS LITTLE I
WORD >> Jim: THERE'S A LOT
MORE THAN WE CAN TALK ABOUT THE
COMMENT BUT MORE THAN A COMMENT.
OUR PRESIDENT TO BE IMPEACHED.
HE DOUBLED DOWN ON IT TODAY.
HE DOUBLED DOWN ON THE COMMENT
SAYING THE MUELLER REPORT
INDICATED HE SHOULD BE
IMPEACHED.
THERE IS NOBODY BESIDES BOB
MUELLER THAT WOULD LIKE TO COME
OUT WITH THAT CONCLUSION.
EVEN HE COULDN'T COME TO THAT
CONCLUSION.
IT IS COMPLETELY RIDICULOUS.
AT THIS POINT, MORE IN COMMON
WITH RASHIDA TO LEAD THAN THE
PRIMARY VOTER IN THE DISTRICT.
SO WE WILL BEAT HIM ON THIS
ISSUE BUT ALSO ON THE FACT THAT
IN TEN YEARS IN CONGRESS, HE'S
GOTTEN ONE BILL PASSED AND IT
WAS A POST OFFICE COMPLETELY
INEFFECTIVE.
NOW, HE WAS ASKED ABOUT ALL THIS
AND LET'S WATCH.
>> >> Laura: VERY
CONDESCENDING.
IT'S NOT SERIOUS.
ARE YOU SERIOUS TONIGHT
MR. LOEHR QUESTION MIKE
>> Jim: 100% AND COME UP VOTE
LOEHR.COM LAUNCHED THOUSANDS OF
DOLLARS IN START UP POINT -- POR
DOLLARS IN START UP POINT -- PON
DOLLARS IN START UP POINT -- POG
AROUND THE STATE OF MICHIGAN AND
THROUGHOUT THE COUNTRY SO 100%
SERIOUS CAMPAIGN AND I'VE WON
HARD IN THE PAST AND WE ARE
GOING TO WIN THIS ONE TOO.
>> Laura: AND THE PAST AND
MORE IS WRITTEN ABOUT THIS
TODAY, HE'S BEEN DOGGED BY HIS
CONNECTIONS WITH CHINA,
FINANCIAL INTEREST IN CHINA,
CHINESE COMPANIES AND I THINK
THAT IS PART OF IT TOO.
THE LIBERTARIANS ARE FINE.
IF WE HAVE TO SELL AMERICANS OUT
TO THE RED CHINESE FOR, YOU
KNOW, SOYBEANS OR SOME HIGH-TECH
EQUIPMENT, SO BE IT.
THAT IS THE SO-CALLED FREE
MARKET.
SO I THINK THAT WILL BE ANOTHER